en la vida cotidiana sabemos que es un
papalote es uno de estos aparatos
voladores de papel o de plástico que
llevamos a pasear cuando vamos a la
playa para volarlo sin embargo los
matemáticos encontraron algunas
propiedades generales de la forma de un
papalote y lo convirtieron en un término
matemático lo convirtieron en una figura
así como los paralelogramo si los rombos
son figuras geométricas los papalotes
también tienen una definición muy
específica que nos permite hacer algunas
cosas matemáticas déjame hablarte acerca
de esa definición específica para
empezar un papalote es un cuadrilátero
pero es un cuadrilátero en el cual
sucede lo siguiente hay dos formas de
definirlo una es decir que tiene dos
pares de lados congruentes aquí se puede
ver que esto sucede de verdad tenemos
que este lado de acá este lado de acá es
congruente a este lado de acá déjame
indicarlo con una rayita y también
tenemos que este lado de acá este lado
de acá
es congruente a este lado de acá y eso
lo voy a marcar con dos rayitas entonces
tenemos dos parejas dos parejas de lados
congruentes esta y ésta pero algo muy
importante es que deben ser lados
adyacentes lo voy a escribir acá tenemos
dos dos pares
de lados congruentes de la dos lados
congruentes
wren test pero algo importante es que
los lados congruentes los lados
congruentes lados congruentes
son adyacentes son adyacentes
ya
antes muy bien ahora cuál es la otra
opción qué sucede si tenemos que dos
pares dos pares de lados congruentes son
opuestos entonces tendríamos un
cuadrilátero más o menos así tendríamos
aquí un lado que sería opuesto a otro
lado y estos dos son congruentes déjame
marcarlo con una rayita y luego
tendríamos voy a tomar la herramienta de
línea este lado de acá que es congruente
a este lado de acá vale y entonces en
esta figura también tenemos dos pares de
lados congruentes pero ahora los lados
congruentes son opuestos
esto de acá no sería un papalote saleh
entonces éste no es un papalote de hecho
es un paralelogramo y es algo de lo cual
ya hemos platicado bastante vale
entonces para que sea papalote debe
tener dos pares de lados congruentes
pero deben ser adyacentes esa es una
forma de definirlo sin embargo también
podemos decirlo de otra forma si te das
cuenta en un papalote se cumple que una
de las diagonales
es un cacho de la media tris de la otra
diagonal es decir también podemos tomar
lo voy a poner en color amarillo un
segmento por aquí considerar su punto
medio su punto medio y tomar otro
segmento que sea perpendicular a éste y
que pase por aquí déjame déjame ver si
me sale más o menos algo de este estilo
exacto entonces esta es otra forma de
hacer un papalote eso de ahí van a ser
las diagonales y ya simplemente unimos
los vértices que quede este con este
este con este este con este y este con
este vale bueno entonces ahí tenemos esa
segunda definición y no voy a aprobar
eso ahorita vale es una propiedad que
nos vamos a creer esto de que las
diagonales sean perpendiculares y de que
una de ellas pasa por la mitad de la
otra vale bueno pero podemos llevar esto
un poco más allá y podemos pensar qué
sucede si ambas diagonales son
perpendiculares la una de la otra es
decir podríamos tener algo del estilo
algo del estilo aquí una diagonal
y por acá otra diagonal y que está no
voy a lo voy a indicar déjame marcarlo
con colores puede ser que esta diagonal
esta diagonal sea media triste de esta
entonces este cachito es igual este
cachito y que también esta diagonal sea
media triz de esta este cachito sea
igual a este cachito este cachito si
unimos la figura si unimos la figura nos
daremos cuenta de que pues sí es un
papalote pero no sólo eso además de ser
un papalote también cumple las
restricciones para hacer otro tipo de
cuadrilátero para hacer un rombo lo voy
a escribir por acá para hacer un rombo
vale entonces tenemos que todos los
rombos son papalotes y en efecto tiene
dos parejas de lados de lados adyacentes
congruentes este con este y este con
éste como el rombo también éste es
congruente a este pero bueno esto
muestra que cumple la condición de ser
papalote vale y esto lo podemos llevar
incluso todavía más allá y pedir que las
dos
mira en lo mismo si las dos diagonales
miden lo mismo entonces tenemos algo de
este estilo
tenemos una diagonal así otra diagonal
que mide lo mismo y pasa por la mitad a
lo mejor no me va a quedar tan bonita la
figura pero bueno el chiste es que si
pedimos todo eso lo que nos lo que se
forma aquí va a ser un cuadrado un
cuadrado vale los cuadrados son tipos
especiales de rombos y tipos especiales
de papalotes aquí la figura no me queda
muy precisa pero todos estos ángulos van
a ser de 90 grados 90 grados 90 grados
90 grados 90 grados y todos los lados
son iguales vale entonces para entender
un poco mejor este mundo de los
cuadriláteros los cuadrados son rombos
los rombos son papalotes pero un
papalote no tiene por qué ser rombo o
porque ser un cuadrado hay muchos otros
tipos de papalotes vale bueno espero que
esto te ayude a comprender un poco más
la idea de papalote y en realidad es muy
fácil identificarlos cuando están en un
problema simplemente se ven como papas